[Music]  gross calling  general wants to see you  there is only one thing harder than  winning a war  keeping peace for the past five years  we co-existed peacefully until now  if we don't find a solution three  billion  will die however we crack their  navigation we're embarking on the first  mission to their world  you've been blessed with the ability to  interact with alien tech  and i want you to join us  give them a taste of their own medicine  that's it oh so you have half a plant  yeah  best  ladies and gentlemen welcome to cobalt  one  anything moves burn it  got movement north wall two signatures  what is it they're surrounding us  we face extermination we'll have to push  beyond our limits  i know what's at stake and i'm not  afraid to die for it  i have to finish this myself  hold on  you